[Music]
[Applause]
well he's still listed as the lead golf
analyst for cbs sports the six-time
major winner nick faldo setting to
retire from broadcasting in august oh
look who's got all the hardware behind
him well done nick well done
nice photo op there
competed against your bobble heads this
is real stuff
man none of those little toys that you
put together get out of a little box you
have to go out and win this baby okay
for those who are listening on radio how
would you describe your uh
oh that's harsh isn't it yes what a what
a comeback okay i'm sitting in front of
my this is my six majors
uh those are the clubs i won the made
clubs and bags everything i kept
everything gloves
i kept the tea pegs i even kept my ball
markers well and the coolest thing
i did uh something i did which i noticed
steven the modern guys don't do billy
foster you know winning
uh on sunday went up and just took the
flag off the top you took the flag i got
the whole flag stick i know message
my caddy put way back andy project from
watford um he put the the
flag
in the bag after we won it open 87
and he said get off and he held it like
that because the green keeper came home
and he says no that's ours so that
started a tradition so i kept it going
luckily but do you then once you won the
majors with those golf clubs you retired
them did you keep playing with those
yeah i did um
so you see a blank bag or a couple of
blank bags so that first set actually
won the next two majors okay
um yeah so there's four yeah four sets
for six majors so um
pretty cool
this might be uh you know tom brady was
on last week he didn't have anything
behind him you know
so he's just got seven footballs i mean
that's not very exciting
you know
a big chunky diamond ring
um i guarantee he'd like to have a set
of clubs
winning a major with i i know he would
he loves his golf doesn't he well what
do you think of his swing
very good i mean i think what those guys
did to go out and play another sport
very brave very brave because you know
it's you're you're out your own comfort
zone to put that on tv
um yeah i i tip my captain ah
so uh very impressive all right uh so
the news uh you're retiring from
broadcasting in august yeah from
full-time broadcast you know you know
i've been out there
i've done 18 seasons 16 with cbs it's
been great next the you know
the legendary gymnast started with
montreal at the start um so you know it
it hits me
at the end of last year that you know
especially with lindsay you know got a
great girl and we want to we got a new
project we bought some land up in
montana
we're fed up with a hustle and bustle we
want to go up there we're calling it
faldo farm it's going to be cuddly
animals i'll be cuddling cows and
alpacas and all sorts of things like
that so you know we wanted to do
something fun
and you need time and even though it's a
six-month season and you think but it
still locks you in
and then you know and then it started
really when you said the best two months
to be in montana september and october
when all the fishing really happens
and so i thought well i don't want to
you know i haven't got enough time to do
a
golf season
and then rush around doing my other
things i still got other things i want
to do
and they're going well
and it was like okay i mean is there a
compromise of a half season and that um
that didn't work for cbs so um
i i'm more than happy i'm i'm
i want to have time for us
to enjoy life
you know you read all these
great philosophers talking about
looking after yourself and you know we
can't buy time
you know you think okay
i want to enjoy myself and do some fun
things at the pace that i want to do
them it's it's as simple as that
were you approached by the live tour to
be an analyst at any point
no
no
did you think you were going to be no
no
i'm surprised that they wouldn't trying
to get
a big name i haven't announced this
officially today
but no i i
i really enjoy
calling championship golf i mean that's
you know i've been with the masters and
the pga
well i'm very fortunate because i'm you
know with with golf channel as well and
then then having the two other opens
i've been in a unique position where
i've been
obviously cbs calling the final play
um
for for at the masters in pga and being
involved through the week
at the other two uh majors the two opens
i was up there obviously last week doing
golf channel um thursday and friday
but i love calling saturday and sunday
golf i mean that's when it really
happens in a championship golf that's
what it's all about
what would you do if you're the
commissioner
if you're j monahan well yeah
we hit they've got a real
interesting dilemma going on now where
pga tour
has taken a stance where you'll be
banned if you go to live and then the
european or i still call european tour
obviously deeply well talk uh saying no
you can come and play that hey i
i
all i know i mean i'm
the line of famous line of forest i'm
not a smart man but you know
there's obviously a long-term project
here i mean i think that's where you've
got to how you got to view this is what
is going to be happening the players are
going to live
must know something more than they're
letting on because
um
i don't get like if well brooks kepler
has just announced you would have
thought brooks would be thinking i can
still win majors so is he happy that
going there he's going to get enough
good golf to prepare himself for the
majors because that's what he's always
said he's interested in
and i think we all agree that the you
know live is tournament is um exhibition
goal three rounds
shotgun start all this sort of thing
um
is not the same as we've seen the last
couple of weeks we cbs we called the
canadian open how fantastic was that
with rory uh getting back in it and then
last week the the open us open
was so darn exciting and gripping stuff
playing on a great golf course
um
great atmosphere but great intensity i
mean how great was that intensity for
the last nine holes of who was going to
win
the us open so obviously delighted for
matt fitz because british young lad and
i've sat with him a couple of couple
breakfast meetings with him over the
years to try and guide him a little bit
so um
and billy foster wonderful guy to get a
wonderful caddy together get a major
under his belt so
you know that's all i'm interested i i i
hope i can still as i said part-time i
hope i still get an opportunity to call
um some of the majors uh in the next
couple of years
yeah and and you you touched on
something there that piqued my interest
that they may know something that we
don't know
what what could these
known
i'm not i i don't know i don't because
i i get the 40 year olds going if you
think if the little voices said you
ain't going to win out here mate
and then shell schwartz was a great
example that guys played half for three
years struggled with injuries you've
probably done 25 tournaments a year
and you've made x i believe it was like
one and a half and then you go one week
and you've won nearly five million so
that and then and they could be looking
at
saying
hey look if i go
to live for two years i'm in my 40s i do
two more years i'm going to make a
boatload i'm going to make tens of tens
of 10 times what i think i could make
busting my butt and with no guarantees
you know so you kind of get that
i don't get the youngsters going to be
honest because
um
i was touting taylor gooch for the last
two years he was my pick saying this guy
is climbing watching he finally wins and
you think i'm you're gonna start you're
on the you're on the ladder young man
you you're slowly learning you're slowly
winning what is next if you want to win
mages well you are climbing you're doing
all the right things to climb forward to
that so to jump and go and play
exhibition golf because
there's something about tournament golf
you know the the fear of missing the cut
is all part of it
and striving to win uh so it's driving
to make the cut is all part of it
because there's a sense of pride
achievement to that you know even the
best in the world world number one if he
if he's got a six footer we saw it twice
this year we saw john rom and rory
mcilroy grinding to make a six footer on
the last on friday evening to make the
cut because they want to play the
weekend and
rahm was 14 back at this example i used
rory then stormed through and nearly won
it up in washington
washington yeah
so you get
so um
and it prepares you for tournament golf
as you're saying if if these guys still
want to play in the majors
yes it's um
they don't like us saying it but
you know
tournament if you believe you can win
majors then you're using the tournaments
jack did it it's preparation for the
next major you you you plan your year
your schedule so you're fully prepared
to give yourself the best chance to win
mates because that's
that's our yardstick that's how we
remember isn't that you know we we know
the numbers
i
honestly you know many players you
haven't got clue how many tournaments
they've won but you know how many majors
have won you know it's so
um and you again
you haven't got a clue how much prize
money they've won but you know how many
mages they've won
so you know that's that's that is our
yardstick and so um
uh
but as you i agree
well what you're saying it's what is the
long-term project on this um and there's
two completely different between us tour
and the rest of the world
on their approach to this and how this
will pan out
we're talking to nick faldo cbs sports
lead golf analyst and a six-time major
winner retiring from broadcasting or at
least full-time broadcasting in august
you're going to be a mess that last day
you and jim nance in the booth i no i'm
not i'm not going to be a mess no and
the lads have been great the you know i
love the guys
and the gals you know we've all been
we've all been a great team
um you know ian baker finch and frank
and trevor um you know real actual
personal friends
so um and obviously jim as well my
goodness and jim is a legend
um
so uh
i'll have to do something to play i
think we should just go off air
i'm rehearsing
the great words of phil collins and he
would say thank you and good night so i
think that might do it
um but have fun in montana and uh you
know well i've got so many good fishing
good mates with huey lewis and he's
introduced me to new fishing buddies
and these are really good fishing
buddies you know the guys who own the
the ranches as well
so um i'm really looking forward to that
you know we we're going to have fun i've
got great go with lindsay we're going to
have animals galore i can't wait to get
it organized yeah i know you know and
i'll be zooming in from minus 25 in i
like that
in the snow
nick how we speak
i think we actually went to the same fly
fishing lodge
what's that i think we went to the same
fly fishing lodge in uh montana oh good
yeah i know i'm proud of you i'm see we
fly fishing he's got to stick together
we love it
we know how good that sport it is and
yeah so maybe you'll have to come and
chip me out of a ditch
chilly next time we talk yeah i'd love
to watch you shovel snow hey um congrats
uh we always appreciate your time and uh
hopefully we'll talk again soon
all right good man all right take care
bobbleheads that's uh nick faldo the uh
lead golf analyst six time major winner
that now that's a backdrop that was
nutty that had all of his clubs his bags
the flag sticks trophies all of his
majors